-Playing tonight, we have
an Oscar-nominated actress
who stars in the new movie
"The Wife."
It's Glenn Close right there!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And from "Stranger Things" and
the upcoming film, "Dog Days,"
it's Finn Wolfhard, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And this is the first puppy
up for grabs tonight.
This is --
This is Kent Wilcox, everybody.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-Oh.
-And here's how the game works.
I'll be asking both of you
animal trivia questions, okay?
-Puppies.
-If you answer correctly,
you win a Golden Doodle puppy.
-Puppy.
-If you answer incorrectly,
your opponent gets the puppy.
-But what about Kent, though?
What's happening with Kent?
-The first question's up
for Kent Wilcox right here.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
You gotta work hard.
This one's for Glenn.
-Yep.
-Ready?
-Mm-hmm.
-You get it right,
you get Glenn -- you get Kent.
Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-What is the technical name
for a group of rabbits?
Is it A, troop,
B, huddle,
or C, fluffle?
[ Laughter ]
-Huddle.
-Judges?
[ Buzzer ]
That is wrong.
It is fluffle, is the real --
-Fluffle?!
[ Laughter ]
-I swear, I swear!
Dude, you get Kent Wilcox.
-No!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know.
It's only the first one.
There's many more puppies.
-Fluffle, wow.
-We have 300 puppies backstage.
-Not 101?
-Not 101.
Oh!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-I'm so mad!
I'm so mad!
[ Laughter ]
I am so mad!
-Kent, like, went down --
-I know.
One Dalmatian -- I know.
Gosh, I'm so mad
I didn't do that.
[ Laughter ]
Next question is for Finn, here.
-All right.
-Finn, who is the most
popular animal on social media,
with more than 8.8 million
Instagram followers?
Is it A, grumpy cat,
B, Doug the Pug,
or C, Jiffpom the Pomeranian?
[ Light laughter ]
-Uh...first of all, Kent looks
like he's seen some stuff.
-Oh, Kent --
[ Laughter ]
No, Kent is totally happy.
-Um, I'm gonna say, just --
[ Audience shouting ]
What?!
[ Laughter ]
I'm gonna say --
I'm gonna say Grumpy Cat.
I'm gonna say, A.
-Judges?
[ Buzzer ]
No. That is wrong.
-It is Jiffpom the Pomeranian.
-Whoa!
Please bring out Layla Storm.
That's the name of this puppy.
-Oh, hello, darling.
Hello, darling.
-That's Layla.
-Good girl.
-That is Layla Storm.
[ Dog barking ]
These are all
newscaster puppies.
Oh, you know
what that sound means.
It's time for Double Puppardy.
Questions are now --
[ Laughter ]
Questions are now worth
two puppies.
-Seriously?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You would make a nice coat.
-When did you make this up?
-We wrote this this afternoon.
Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
Now, here we go.
Glenn, this is for you.
Which of these
is not a historical nickname
for the Dalmatian?
Is it, A, Plum Pudding Dog,
B, Cow Hound,
or C, Spotted Dick?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Um, cow --
-You should know.
-I mean,
you would think it was C.
-You'd think.
-But, uh...
-I know. I know.
-I'll do...
-That's what makes the game fun.
Uh, Spotted Dick, C.
-Spotted Dick.
Judges?
[ Buzzer ]
No, they are called
Spotted Dick.
Cow Hound is the answer.
-Cow hound?
-Let's bring out...
-...Rhonda Jiparski
and Chip Gibbons.
-Oh, my goodness.
-These are all news --
[ Laughs ]
-These are all --
These are all --
These are all
newscaster puppies.
So that was Rhonda Jiparski
and Chip Gibbons.
[ Laughter ]
-I feel like --
I feel like these --
I feel like I'm, like,
a therapist for some reason.
-Yeah.
-Like, "Guys, what's --
what's going on?"
-No, they're --
they're loving you right now.
-No, it's good.
It's a good relationship.
I feel like we've formed a bond.
-Yeah. Get in there, man.
Yeah.
-Yeah.
-Finn, here we go.
To win more puppies...
[ Light laughter ]
-What is the national animal
of Scotland?
Is it A, sheep,
B, honey badger,
or C, unicorn?
National animal of Scotland.
-Dude, if it's unicorn,
I'm gonna be so mad.
[ Laughter ]
Um, which I know it's not.
Dude, if --
Is sheep -- Is sheep Ireland?
Dude, oh.
What do you think?!
[ Laughter ]
Just give me the answer.
-No hints, no hints.
-Um, I'm gonna say sheep.
-No.
It is the unicorn.
Can you believe that?
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Is that unbelievable --
-That is not a real animal.
-Dude.
-Sorry.
-It's not a real animal.
-It's the unicorn.
All right.
Please bring out...
♪♪
This is Kwame Evans
and Tad Rickman.
-Oh, come here, my darlings.
-Kwame and -- Oh, come on.
-Oh, my darling puppies.
Come here.
-I heard Kent --
I heard Kent say "sheep."
[ Dog barking ]
Ooh! That sounds means
it's time for Final Puppardy.
[ Laughter ]
-This is for all
of your opponent's puppies.
-Oh, great.
-And what a tight game we have.
-They never help me.
I'm bitter.
[ Laughter ]
-Here we go.
If you can, pick up the iPads
next to your chairs.
-Oh, God.
Yeah.
Kent, can you grab it?
-We made this very hard for you.
Here you go, Finn.
-Oh, thanks, man.
-Yeah, no problem.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
-That was weird.
It almost seemed like a weird
hand came out of nowhere.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
Glenn, ready for this?
-Yeah, I am.
-Now this is a numbers question.
You're gonna
write down your answers,
and whoever is closer
to the correct answer
is the "Pup Quiz" champion.
In 2012, two dogs were married
in the most expensive
pet wedding of all time.
What was the total cost
of the wedding?
♪♪
How much would a giant wedding
be for two dogs?
Whoever comes closest
is the winner.
Oh, you have 10 seconds.
Sorry.
You have 3 seconds left.
Two seconds, one.
[ Buzzer ]
There you go.
All right, very good.
-My iPad's not working.
-Uh, Finn, you can just
say your answer out loud.
-I'm gonna say $6 million.
-$6 million?
Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
I'm just gonna crown the champ.
-$1 million.
-$1 million?
The correct answer -- $250,000.
Glenn, you're the closest!
Glenn Close is the champion,
right there!
Come here, buddy.
Come here.
Glenn gets all your puppies.
-Aww.
-Sorry, dude.
-Oh, my darlings.
-He got in there.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
Glenn gets all the puppies.
Here.
-I'm sorry.
-[ Laughing ]
I'm sorry.
-Kent, he has to go.
There he goes.
-I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-Aw, there you go.
The champ right there.
Glenn Close, everybody.
Finn Wolfhard.
Thank you
to these adorable puppies.
We're talking to Glenn
after the break.
Everybody gets a puppy!
Stick around!
[ Cheers and applause ]